the jurogan experience there's always
been that situation too where you have
these really hungry talented artists and
they get taken advantage of
by whether it's executives or who
whoever is the the money people that
figure out
how to lock these people into some
long-term contract where
the lion's share of all their work and
creativity is going to be
enjoyed by the company and not by the
artists themselves you always have these
crazy that part of the models i mean
hopefully there's enough pie to go
around everybody
is kind of okay with that i mean there's
a certain number you get to where you
probably don't care anymore how much
they're making because you're making so
much also you know
but uh i but that model
that's that that's not a mystery
especially if you're like coming up the
times like when i came up like we
already knew all that is if you got if
you got locked into a bad record
contract where somebody screwed you over
like it's kind of on you a little bit it
wasn't like it's not the 50s the 60s
where
like we stepped into things and didn't
know uh and it has nothing with my
background
i never got screwed over though the
worst people i've ever met in this
business were the bands
they were not they were not the labels
because you know who they are you know
what they're doing
they don't really change you're not
gonna you won't be fooled you know it's
the people that you have camaraderie
with that you think are in
the trenches with you that you find out
like those people let you down more
that you get hoodwinked by the business
people you
there's no secret what they're doing
have you been you've been hoodwinked by
other artists everybody has really
yeah i just unless i'm not making a
point about artists or shitty i'm just
saying
the big bad record business like not not
for me not my days i've worked some
great people
you know some really supportive uh um
positive people who've been a great part
of my career
you know i i actually can't i can only
name like i can name 30 years maybe like
one or two people i came across who i
hope i never see again
in that end of the business otherwise
that's a pretty good ratio that is a
very good ratio
so essentially there's always going to
be people that take advantage of people
that don't really understand
or are too eager and accept a bad
contract
yeah but there's no excuses for not
reading that we're just too far along
like you just it shouldn't be that easy
to fool someone today
i've been offered a lot of bad contracts
but i didn't sign them either
you know right so same kind of situation
and i've been in situations where i've
looked at a contract and it's that's the
nature of most business deals that
someone's gonna do better than somebody
else
right so when you look at that you
realize it looks like you're no matter
what gonna do but this isn't a good
situation like
it's i don't take that as like a
personal attacker it's like okay well
this isn't good for me it's not good
we'll just i'll go find somewhere else
to do this just
they're just establishing shitty rules
for the game but there's no connect yeah
right but they're
they're in business right you know it's
like again prince what was his uh
what did he say they owned his name
right i think it was something uh
they me i'm gonna get the quote wrong
but somewhere around the time where he
changed his just
the symbol and they said something but
somebody said something about the record
business he said no i'm not in the
record business
you're in the record business i make
music you know and that's
that's kind of it that's that's true but
they're not
there's no there's no similarities to
them there's no reason you have
that you're a great talent that you
should also have a great understanding
of the business side of things you're
not really interconnected for most
people
but we are far enough along now where
hopefully you have somebody with you
and things are more transparent that you
shouldn't get locked into these horrible
deals anymore
do you remember when courtney love wrote
that piece
where she was explaining the music i
think it was in spin magazine
where she was explaining the music
business in terms of like
where the money goes and how they [ __ ]
over artists do you remember that
i don't remember that but then don't get
in the music business that's not new
i mean it's not is that a revelation did
you read that or like wow
like it was shocking to me because i'm
not in the music business so to me i was
like wow so that's how they do it
yeah i was i was confused like when it
went into like
you know if you're a band people bands
don't do this anymore if your band sells
two million records everybody in that
band is probably making a lot of money
buying houses
right and that cd cost eighteen dollars
like you're making your money you're
pretty happy it's only down the road
where someone says okay you guys you did
buy a house did you see how much
that they made and you are shocked for a
second to realize
you take that seat and you divide it up
between yourselves your band and
with the record yeah they make a lot
more than you hmm that's why they're in
the record business
and they're you know some of them are
too smart to be in the bands
or not smart enough well it depends on
what what you can handle if you can
i couldn't handle that kind of lifestyle
myself i don't i don't want i i'm like
i invent things at nothing i don't want
to be somebody who
i have my whole livelihood is
reactionary to other people
creating something that i can now work
with right i want to
make it from scratch yeah that's a weird
situation to be in relying upon other
people's creativity
yeah for you to make a living yeah and
but you know you can do that when you
don't have a com
you don't have a a creative bone in your
body some people are really good at
numbers in math some people are really
creative you know and if you recognize
early on well i would like to
i mean i said a lot of the great people
who work outside of bands once wanted to
be in a band but realize
like i don't have it i love music but i
want to be a part of it anyway i want to
help someone else do great things
you know right but i i'm not the guy to
be in the band or the girl
if you have your own music and you own
your music
what is what does a record label do for
you in 2021
well what do you mean if you own your
own music if you like if you create your
own music
right you say you hire what could a
record label do for you yeah they have
money that you don't have to promote and
spend and put you on tour
you know young bands need they can't you
know
a van or no van it costs money to tour a
lot
you know so so they basically loan you
the money
that's what that's how they can be good
for a young band really or any band any
you know it's like otherwise you
you don't have the tools the assets to
get your music in lots of places i mean
there's more opportunities with social
media of course
and it's you know look the good news is
anybody can do it now and the bad news
is anybody can do it now it just means
it's crowded and it's just like it's
hard to know what anybody's up to
you know but now record labels they can
still have a great they have a great
purpose
of course you know they're you some
people say they're banks
they're just funding your trip and you
have you have a big bill at the end
and they have a connection to streaming
services yeah they have all those
contacts that
that you uh that you wouldn't have on
your own now when a person is like say
if you're a new band
and you get signed by a record company
how does someone find out about you
i mean what is the primary way they find
out about you if it's not the radio
which it always used to be
do they find out about you through
streaming services like are there
channels that are sponsored that people
get excited about because they know that
this channel is where
new interesting music gets broken we're
both
gonna do some home we're gonna do some
homework after this and if i find out
i'll let you know
i mean really that's the well that's the
question i don't know i mean because
there's
it's just jammed up everywhere you know
so a lot of great things about the way
things work now
the models that we had before were
really effective too and at least you
could put yourself on a path
that if you did x y and z maybe your
band would get a shot
you know play your clubs get your demo
tape together maybe a rec company wants
to work with you
they're gonna give you some money to
practice you know you make that record
you make a video and you go and give you
some money to go on tour like this was a
path
to maybe being a band that was
successful so you take that away
you know it is just every man from every
man and woman for themselves
just you know trying to find a way to
quote unquote kind of get lucky
you know if you're an established act
you got up you've got opportunities if
you're doing it the other way
you're just it's really everybody's
trying to get lucky and then by the and
when someone sees what that person did
by the time you figure it out it's too
late
it's gotta do something else everyone
that's what it is i mean as far as i
know
you know but i'm also not brand new
like if i was 21 years old i'd probably
understand this better than i do
you know i the way i came up was just a
different i mean
it was just a different model and that's
okay that a lot of that's gone
i mean it's changed so drastically i
mean remember
in the late like nineties that remember
you know what the diamond award was
no that's when they had to invent it
there was you know gold record platinum
record
it wasn't enough people were going like
12 times platinum so they invented the
diamond award which was 10 million
whoa the diamond award yeah that's how
much money was going around in those
days
before the internet really how many
people buy cds today
do they still sell i don't know where
you buy one
online i guess i guess uh amazon yeah
they're still i mean
yeah i mean i guess you where are you
gonna play it i mean
laptops don't even have hard drives
vinyl sells more than cds right now but
i might get a breakdown real quick
that's interesting
oh for sure no no it actually flopped
they don't it was for a while like a
bonus if your company want to spend some
money make vinyl with you now it's kind
of like
you can throw in cds but the production
of that is like you know
yeah it's the cardboard you put around
it it's cool now to have vinyl
yeah these don't they don't seem cool
but why would you have see
i mean streaming is one thing i mean see
these are
oh wow streaming's 83 percent of music
industry venue wow think what is sync
that's getting your songs in tv and in
commercials and you get licenses
so that's two percent physical nine
percent
is uh physical so that's live
performances no physical is a
combination of cds and nlps and
oh physical things oh i get it and then
digital downloads are six percent so
physical
copies are just nine we're taking up the
bulk of that pie right there
and then streaming takes up the bulk of
the pie so
yeah oh interesting so cds and it's kind
of
uh in 2020. what is happening in 2020
says what uh
it's more vinyl than it is uh cd
and others what are we looking at that's
the the green and the blue that's ocd
the green is vinyl which is the largest
vinyl is not like blowing up
anybody tells you it's back it's not
like it's not it's not you know not
buying kiss right not like kiss records
in those days right
it's for it's a boutique kind of thing
it's cool catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience